hi everyone
thank you so much for joining us today
welcome to the rcdo enterprise community
meetup i'm rachel calling in from boston
well really dorchester today
today we're going to learn more and chat
with each other about a crucially
important topic accessibility
ultimately making sure that our data
products can be used by all users
if you've just joined now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window
say hello maybe where you're calling in
from
i do
also want to make note that if you want
to turn on live transcription
during the meetup you can do so in the
zoom bar
below where it says more
to go through a brief agenda we'll have
some short introductions and welcome
everyone to the meetup
we'll have a presentation by maya
a11 y and r or ally and r we are just
talking about how you say that
followed by a presentation by mara
on the high charts accessibility module
and then a lot of time for
q a and open discussion discussion to
share resources with each other as well
so after the press presentation we'll
have lots of time for q a
but can also ask a few right after each
of the presentations too
just a reminder that this meetup will be
recorded and shared to the rstudio
youtube
so if you do ask questions in the zoom
chat
you'll be part of of that recording
if you want to ask questions anonymously
you can do so as well we have a slido
link for that and i'll put that in the
chat window here in just a moment
but for anybody who's joining for the
first time a special welcome to you all
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for teams to share the work
that you're doing within your
organizations teach lessons learn
network with each other
really just to allow us all to learn
from each other
so thank you all so much for making this
a welcoming community too
i really want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
i always like to reiterate this that we
love to hear from everyone no matter
your level of experience in the field
too
i'll share a few other links in the chat
window too if you do ever have
suggestions or want to speak at one of
these in the future love to hear from
you
but with that that's enough from me
thank you all again for joining us i'd
love to turn it over to our first
speaker maya ganz
maya is a data visualization engineer at
a taurus research where she develops
custom applications using r and
javascript
i'll stop my share and turn it over to
you
awesome thanks so much
hey everyone i am so excited to talk
about this topic today uh but a couple
caveats first one this is the topic that
i'm super passionate about as of recent
i am not an expert in this but i think
that it is imperative that we all make
considerations for accessibility and
the second thing is that i personally
when creating this talk or creating
websites visualizations whatever it is
i have my own data visualization uh
blind spots um
and
so
yeah that's that's just how i just
wanted to caveat that that said
this is a really cool topic and i think
we all need to be considering it um as
rachel mentioned the talk is called a
11t or ally or
accessibility in r there are 11 letters
between a and y in accessibility and
that is long and that is why it is
abbreviated as such
um
and
again i am not an expert but sarah
alfossheim is
and their blog posts are incredible
amazing resources i will be sharing
these slides and the all the links are
clickable
therein and sarah their blog post goes
over has a blog post where they go over
10 g's and don'ts in data visualization
so i figured i can adapt those into the
r ecosystem
so
the blog post begins saying
accessibility should always be a focus
when designing products and the same
goes with working with data
visualizations and graphs
so the
main tenant of the internet is that
everyone should have access to it and
likewise we should be thinking about
data visualizations in the same way
thinking about our audience who's
consuming them and they should be
consumable by all
so
i'll just
jump in to our first tenant here don't
rely on color to explain the data so i
just made a quick bar chart here of
where they're grouped by some category
you'll see the code on the left hand
side there
and
there are many applications in to do
this but here i've linked cobles you can
throw in any image
into this application and it'll show you
the various forms of uh
colorblindness and you'll see here like
this one specifically you have that
middle bar and the top colors are really
close together so
throwing your data visualizations into
software like this is a quick and easy
win to think about um how you're going
to leverage different colors
oh
okay i click on that link um
cool so
what can we do
there is a really cool package gg
pattern which this is my first time
playing with it um
you can if your company has a you know
really strict color palette that is
failing some of these color blind tests
you can leverage different patterns uh
so
here we have different patterns denoting
the different categories as well so
leveraging this with the redundancy of
color can help to bridge that gap
okay
here is
for anyone in this talk that knows me
being extra is kind of my mo
so
the second tenant is don't use very
bright or low contrast colors so i
obviously had to make a custom shiny
input widget
where you can
scroll to
see the text color on the background
color and if it passes
the wcag um
standards there are double a and aaa
standards which are the less and more
strict if your website is not passing
the less strict one
boo
bad so this there's color checkers
online but again me being extra i made a
little package and made a contrast
checker so
because this is an r thing um we could
talk about color math that's a little
bit beyond the scope of the talk but you
feel free to play with this in the
slides
all right
ten and three this is a really good one
and honestly very fun to play with don't
hide important data behind interactions
when thinking about accessibility
something that we have to think about is
how
many consumers of
data are doing so on mobile that is
their primary means of
getting and uh consuming data so
on the left hand side i have a plotly
data visualization where on hover i'm
seeing some drill down the value of
these
uh
of the chunks here the that make the
categories that comprise the whole bar
that's really cool but on mobile we
don't really have a hover
so what we can do is leverage click
events so now
when i click here
imagine on mobile you have your plot and
then under it i have some container that
will populate with that metadata um and
what i'm doing here is clicking on each
of these uh
each of these categories
so for anyone who wants to geek out over
the code
on the left hand side all i want you to
focus on is the hover template i created
a custom hover template and plotly um
and then for the click event which is a
little more involved you have to create
that container element so i've made that
container and called it plotly output
so that's just empty and then
using the html widgets package i attach
an on render function for the plotly
object
where on click
you grab that element
and then shove in the data that you get
on click which plotly
helps you to leverage that click event
so
going over the specifics of this code is
like my bread and butter i love this
stuff and i love to live in this
world and thinking about how desktop
consumers are different than mobile
consumers but the specifics of the code
a little bit overboard for this talk
that said if anyone wants to reach out
to me twitter linkedin whatever i i am
psyched to talk about this stuff
okay
number four don't overwhelm the user
with information
when you google dashboard fatigue i
think the first thing that comes up is
shawn lop of our studio
his talk
on dashboard fatigue and how to mitigate
that
what is dashboard fatigue when you throw
it is as a data scientist with us
uh statistical background and not a ui
background it is very tempting to shove
all the things into the dashboard
because we have access to all the things
uh bachon
urges us to reel it back
and the goal of data science of a data
science team is to help organizations or
individuals make better decisions
informed by data don't show me
everything about everything what is it
the user needs
only show them that
and then when designing a dashboard it's
important to think about leading with
the key data make that bold and font
size 100 or make that visual the biggest
one
and then
two other considerations for not
overwhelming the user is to limit the
view the scope and then let the user
this is uh
this is like the power of shiny right
where we can let the user change how
they filter the data and their focus
slice and dice the data in different
ways hand that power over to the user
rather than just saying here's 700 plots
have fun
um and then finally a favorite of mine
that i see in the wild a lot is when
people don't use consistent language in
color so example
plot a and ploppy are have the same x
axis
but plot a says person one two three and
plot b says one two three they're
literally the same thing but you're not
using the same like nomenclature
bad um the second
thing is
um using consistent color so in plot a
person one two three is red green blue
and then in plot b you're using a gray
scale but those colors mean the same
thing across plots
try to think of your dashboard as
telling a data story and being cohesive
throughout that story
so
what kind of covers for there
number five
use accessibility tools when designing
so rachel mentioned that later we can
all geek out and share links because
that is the point of these meetups for
us to all learn more um
so
the biggest link here is the web content
accessibility guidelines this is the
tone of
all
all the things that you should be
considering for accessibility when
creating a website and then you can just
glean nuggets from that when creating
data visualizations here's a different
color contrast validator then the shiny
one that i created
um
google lighthouse is an incredible tool
that you can run on any website i
recommend you if you're using um
like a package down or
block down or whatever down
run this on your websites and it will
check
it gives you a grade if you're
and it checks things like the color
contrast checker that i created it
checks things like do all your images
have alt text tags and it'll walk you
through how to make your score 100. um
so google lighthouse is an incredible
tool
and then there's the 11t project
checklist which is a great checklist to
mentally or literally physically go
through when creating a data
visualization make sure that you
cross off everything and consider
everything outside of your own personal
biases when creating a data
visualization
so all these links live in the talk
um okay
use patterns and shapes in addition to
color this one is a little
we talked about it a little bit in point
one
here in the code i have the color is
equal to category
um
but use some redundancy there i out i
also added the shape is equal to the
category this might seem redundant to
you but it could be really helpful to
others simple effective just do it
using labels and legends
so
it is
perfectly adequate to create to use the
ggplot default legend that is going to
create this color by person
um legend for you but i urge you to be
creative and let your plot readers be as
lazy as possible i love a transition
where i get to read this line and boom
i'm right into person three i don't need
my eyes are doing the least amount of
work possible so this is just a simple
example of how we can
use our creativity to
uh leverage labels and legends and i
included
the code here because you have to do
some shenanigans with shifting the
margins and over to
in order to add text outside of the plot
i thought that was a fun
little neat trick so
happy to go over that code it exists
here for you to
leverage
all right
this is a slide that is a talk in and of
itself so i will and will lends itself
to
mars talk but there is a library called
charitability
and this is a plot i did not make it was
made by friend frank elvaski alaski i
believe
this package is from visa but do not
quote me on that this will link out to
the observable notebook where this plot
was created
um
in all of my examples till this point
i've been using png's with alt text to
describe the data visualization and when
writing alt text
you want to really think about if you
were to call your friend on the phone
and describe the data
visualization that is what you want to
put don't just put this is a bar graph
that's that's i didn't get anything from
that right
so
what
is awesome about the internet is that it
uses html which is a hierarchical uh
markdown language and also learning html
is a little bit beyond the scope of this
but i just want to show how
this
library because it's not a png elements
are clickable
and here what i did is i
clicked or you can hit tab to focus on
the whole plot
and then
when you
i'm clearly not a
keyboard navigator um when you hit enter
it's so html is hierarchical so hitting
hitting tab
will find
sibling elements hitting enter you'll go
into the tree so here i've hit enter to
go into
into the plot itself and then i can hit
enter again
and the screen screen readers will read
to me
that this bar segment is of count 4
category current status and it's about
the topics covered and because this 4 is
a sibling element
to
the
4 i can now hit my left and right arrow
keys
to
navigate to the 41. um
this experience of using
the keyboard and not using a mouse at
all i urge everyone to do this so i am
very much a mac user but just going over
to
a blank slate google page here if i hit
command f5
welcome to voiceover
voiceover speaks descriptions of items
on the screen and can be used to control
the computer using only your keyboard we
if you already know how to use voiceover
press the v key now
if you want to learn how to use voip so
we can use f5 to use the voice over um
link about link about link store
joslin has entered the waiting room
press cmd plus to open pop-up or go to
the participants panel to admit which is
joslyn audio sub menu stop david doyle
has left the meeting chrome google
google chrome maya window link voice
over off
so
i
am a super voice over novice i couldn't
even tab from zoom which is
what i'm using into this actual google
window
and
um that is why i
urge people to play with this and
navigate through
using only a keyboard and
um at the very least we if you are a
shiny app developer if you can take from
this talk to tab through your
application and see what that user
workflow looks like
that would be a huge win on my end so
again i urge people to explore using a
screen reader and how if that's a new
uh way to experience using a computer
for you as it is for me it can be
incredibly it's you want to consider the
things that people are going to be
tabbing through maybe
leveraging uh shortcuts in order to make
tabbing easier for them and thinking
about keyboard shortcuts and all that
kind of stuff is actually really fun
uh as a like a side example if you use a
um screen reader on twitter the first
thing it reads to you is an element that
a sighted user is never going to
interact with it reads out all the core
keyboard shortcuts to use when
navigating through the website so that
you can
uh leverage all the things that someone
who can use who's using a mouse could do
okay so that is a whole side of using a
screen reader
that i'm clearly need some work doing um
but is a whole another world of
experiencing the internet
all right
number nine is providing context and
explaining your visualization and i
the way that i did this is using the
annotate function
um
which is your best friend here to add
labels i realize this text is super
small but at the bottom of the plot i
added all-time low and at the highest
point in the plot i added record high
this gives the user some
uh broader context for if this if you
have a graph of some snapshot in time
but this is a record high temperature in
the past decade or whatever like
it's it leverage text
to really highlight those important
narratives
another example here
is i've created a bar plot and you
immediately are going to go to the
uh maroon segment here because i've
leveraged both color and some text which
i very creatively wrote some event worth
highlighting um because that's where
your eye is just going to immediately go
there so again providing context
explaining
the visualization thinking about your
audience what they know what they don't
know and
really trying to communicate that story
and then my last
by miami sarah's last uh
tenant here is to focus on accessibility
during user interviews so this
applies more to creating dashboards and
shiny apps than it does to a single
static data visualization
but
you still can
uh oh you should always be applying uh
this first part in the preparation of
creating anything
um you should give user personas
disabilities so first of all what is a
user persona when creating
a website or visualization or whatever
that you want people that are not
yourself to consume it is really helpful
to create detailed narratives of people
who are going to be using this
application
um
sarah who's the head of hr is blah blah
blah blah she's going to be navigating
through the application to do this and
bob who's this is going to be doing that
right so
flushing out those stories um
will help you to live outside of your
subjective biases when creating these
applications
the next step after preparing is
recruiting
uh when
getting people to participate in any of
your user studies you want to make sure
you set one on one time
you might want to consider a ride share
or something like that you don't know
what people's transportation
needs are and then finally you want to
inquire about the assistive technology
used which kind of goes into my last one
here when you're conducting the
interview if i were to take a poll for
all the people in this room just some
different mechanical keyboards that
people use like we all have vastly
different setups and preferences and
everyone
in programming is opinionated so people
are
are gonna have different hardware um so
if you create an application with one
kind of uh
accessibility hardware in mind and then
someone brings in a joystick you need to
account for that and maybe also have
some like av people there to
to help you with that because even
though i'm a programmer i don't know how
to use a projector so that could be
helpful
and then
lastly you want to just consider that
when scheduling these kind of interviews
and people work
using your application uh that they'll
these
might take longer because as you saw
with the screen reader there's there's a
lot that goes on there so
again i'll give out these slides there's
links about
um
i
hope that i was able to
impart some wisdom here and i hope that
if you are new to
employing ally techniques into your data
visualization that you share with us
kind of what you learn and
yeah
i'm excited to be here and talk with you
all
thank you so much maya
i always like to say we're all clapping
even though you can't hear us right now
we can use the little zoom reactions
though
um thank you so much for all of that
i see there's a lot of questions that
have started to come in through both the
chat
as well as slido so i'm going to do my
best to to navigate those
but one of the anonymous questions was
the principle of contrast checker is
also applicable for the spatial for
spatial data map visualizations
is that true
sure
mara you're nodding so
yeah so we think so if anyone had i
think that i think that was a statement
not a question it would i read it as it
was written but it there was a question
mark yes
at the end
so let me rephrase it so well it's also
there's different
um
contrast that you want to look for it's
contrast checkers are for
um like the ratio of contrast for text
as opposed to
color blindness checkers which
look at
um
what people with different
um
vision
situations see so they're a little bit
different but there are checkers for
both and they're ones that are
specifically for maps
awesome yeah i see caleb put in the chat
too cartographer here and i would say
yes
awesome
um and this is all i just want to caveat
too sorry that this is all like uh you
know
uh a learning experience i guess for me
and thinking about your
you know outside of your subjective
biases like if there is a
a gradient that you're using a default
gradient
and you don't know how to create a
custom gradient then leverage all text
leverage descriptions leverage you know
what i mean so it's okay
if you're not up to the highest
standards in
wic tag but you then use the other tools
if you can you know what i mean
that's a great point maya
let me go over to a question from
the chat over here on zoom
oh let's see
um i see nils
had asked are you using a custom
sherigan theme and i always say that
word wrong
um i
live
for
customizing my sharing slides and
yes i am uh i use a combination of canva
creating background images and then
importing them into the slides and
talk about talk about extra happy to go
down that rabbit hole
outside of the scope of this talk though
awesome thank you maya
let me just see if there
actually if anyone has one more question
before we go over to mara
we will have lots of time for question
after too
um feel free to just raise your hand on
zoom too
i see friends cisco you just asked the
question in the chat if you'd wanna
unmute yourself and ask live too
oh i think i turn on the ability to
unmute yourself
i can read it too the question was i
wonder if maya could quickly talk about
her process of creating a visualization
and adding accessibility layers
do you follow the principles in order
that's an awesome question again
hurricane back to my caveat of this
being a very new world for me but i find
this incredibly fun and important um
there
in the slide deck there's a link to a
checklist uh so that is what i've
recently been considering um and then i
use a combination i always use
lighthouse checks when i'm creating
shiny apps to make sure that it all my
html elements are passing everything uh
but i think
yeah that's a really good question i
think it's a matter of synthesizing
people who are smarter than me their
information and um
i'm happy to share like through blog
posts and meetings like this as i learn
more but uh
i think that checklist is a good place
to start
perfect thank you so much maya
i'd love to turn it over to
mara for our second presentation and
again we'll have other time for
questions for both maya and mara at the
end and open discussion too
um so i will say if you're using slido
to ask questions it'd be really helpful
or actually
if you're using zoom chat too really
helpful to include mara or maya's name
if the questions directed to either one
of them too
but thank you so much to introduce our
next speaker we have mara ivrik and mara
is a developer advocate
at our studio
i'll turn it over to you mara awesome
oh wait
hi um can you hear me
i can hear you and i can see your slides
awesome great so um i i am using
quarto which
you'll learn about in future times but
um
or you have already learned about anyway
this is my first time doing this with
porto and
um
i will say
this writing this like very brief talk
took me way longer than
probably any other talk i've ever
written and
really not for lack of materials i did
write a five part
series of blog posts covering this topic
but
in part because um
they're
like i've fallen down the accessibility
rabbit hole right there's so much to
learn and it's really interesting and i
noticed somebody commented on maya's um
font at one point they're like oh like
thanks for using a mono space font like
you have no idea how much time i spent
being like okay well there's atkinson
hyper legible which is good
for like distinguishing characters but
that's not as good like that's good for
open dyslexic but it's not as good for
cognitive disabilities where you want to
have familiar looking shapes
there's a lot you know like
accessibility is not one size fits all
at all um and i ended up talking about
like stealing from experts i this i'm
using noto sans which is what they use
on the ally project and the
um
the
world wide web consortium on web
accessibility initiative for their
slides and presentations so i was like
if it was good enough for them
it's good enough for me but
i i just noticed that anyway
rachel kind of covered this about me my
name is mara developer advocated our
studio i live in missoula where it is a
balmy 14 degrees right now
um
things i did not create
high charter that's um good old joshua
kunst who is an our package developer
high charts
that's done by hisoft
um
and just so you know that's not um a
complete list of the things that i have
not created
but i wasn't gonna list all of this
anyway um so high charts is it is a
javascript charting library based on svg
um that makes it easy for developers to
create
interactive and accessible charts um the
svg part comes in quite a lot
um
but so i i want to disambiguate what the
two things are um and high charter is an
r wrapper for the high charts javascript
library and its modules
um and how did i fall into this so
sylvia can alone wrote a great um post
on
resources for database accessibility um
and they are these general and our
specific resources on how and why to
make accessible data visualizations and
at the time of its first rating um
the high charts accessibility module
didn't seem to be working with the high
charter package um and i've used high
charter before
and um
i kind of
remembered i was like you know what like
i i'm not a javascript developer but if
you can make it work in high charts you
can usually make it work in high charter
so
i am deciding to see if i could do it so
my motivate there were a couple of
github issues people had filed and this
was my like great motivating example was
somebody filed an issue saying that
keyboard navigation wasn't working um
and
you know what's really fun by the way
using keyboard navigation
when you're trying to present oh i did i
was doing it right when you're trying to
present a slide deck that uses keyboard
navigation but um trust me i am using my
my
keyboard right now you can see look i
did make it work
um and look i can even
use my keyboard to do something like
view it as a data table
um which turns out people want that and
then i could go back and hide the data
now i'm using my mouse um i could export
the data i could export it as svg
hooray i made it work
and this was not the end of the story
um oh shoot now i'm like stuck in
there we go
sorry
uh
anyway so
if we take
my journey at the starting point reading
sylvia's fantastic post
the endpoint written a five-part series
on how to do these things with
increasingly complex
visualizations
they're
the posts have these accessible examples
with high charter and all this r code
which is pretty long
um
but
in the middle here is me learning a
bunch of useful things um
non-code or framework specific a lot of
great things from high charts and high
charter but also things that apply in
general and um
this talk will be covering that middle
point sorry i know everyone's going to
be disappointed by me not reading a lot
of code aloud but
um yeah it's it's there for you to
peruse and i also um
i also want to
tell you some of the the general
principles um that can be applied from
high charts and high charter to your
visualizations in general
so
a little bit of background on high
charts and accessibility
um
so one thing which is this is not to say
that it's perfect but
high charts is not free for commercial
use and it's like a key selling point
for them uh tons of companies have to
comply with accessibility like 508 our
regulations in the us
um and it's a key part of their business
model um a lot of companies were already
using them before this became the case
but um
that's a thing so some of their features
very much this is like not
at all exhaustive it's keyboard
navigation
screen reader optimization um
low vision features sonification voice
input tactile export so as you can
already probably tell there that
actually accommodates a lot of
different types of accessibility needs
so for example voice input for people
who um have trouble using the keyboard
um which is another population uh it
turns out people who use screen readers
have really different preferences i'll
get into more detail about that later
um
so the background on this is that
high charter or sorry high charts um did
a collaboration with elsevier um oysteen
mohsen is one of the core developers for
high charts and
ted geez is from
elsevier elsevier sorry if i'm saying it
wrong um
and
both of whom they're members of the
database accessibility advocacy and
advisory group um but they kind of got
together um
to elsevier was actually already using
highcharts and ted had a lot of
background in um
user testing and they embarked on this
journey of kind of developing and
developing this product together through
iterative
both accessibility expert testing and
user testing
and that's really key
so this is just
one
quotation from an article
about the project that they did from
lucy greco who's a web accessibility
evangelist she was one of their test
users um and she's been blind since
birth she said you know kind of this
innovation allows me to interact with
the chart and understand the
relationships of all the components of
the chart to all the other components
rather than just getting a description
of the chart um and that is enabled by
the fact that these are svg and
i
full disclosure like don't know a ton
about svg they've made it work um and
you can drill down in it i would never
be able to come up with that i'm not an
expert and i also don't have user
testing so this is one of those cases
where um
sometimes using the right tool teaches
you a lot and um
again accessibility is hard so i like
using this tool
so
more background if you're curious
they
did
the two of them have um
presented at the csun access assistive
technology conference is like one of the
biggest assistant technology conferences
they've
um
they've presented several times um and i
really highly recommend this video
interview this is i i know this is like
a very oh can you see that i'm hovering
over that
can you see it now yes i can okay cool
um
there are a lot of links in here that i
hope that you take a look at that but
that video interview is one of them it's
short and it really tells you a lot um
other collaborations that high charts
has done uh with the georgia text
notification lab they made a completely
open source high chart sonification
studio
because of how i'm navigating through
things by trying to open it
things are going to go a little crazy so
i'm not going to but very neat to check
out if you want to
later
all right so some of the features so
keyboard navigation um users are able to
navigate and interact with
several components right so the data
points the chart menu and other chart
controls using the keyboard only so this
kind of goes beyond just being able to
get
to the chart or around the web page on
the whole this means that they can um
interact with individual elements
um and
an example of that and this one i didn't
make and again i'm going to have trouble
showing the keyboard navigation
awesomeness from
presenter view
uh
let me see if i can get it going by
unclicking this and then using my
keyboard
um i can't but trust me that you can
navigate these things and also you'll
have this slide so you can see for
yourselves
um
and i did not create that one but here
is one um that i did pre-create in our
with highcharter um and one of the
things that they found in their research
um by the way this
since i made this they've changed their
default color scheme to be more
accessible by the way but it also
uses dual encoding as you can see there
are shapes and patterns that are used
for each of these lines i'm navigating
with the mouse right now because of my
keyboard issues but
um what they found in their research was
that
am i doing this yes okay now i'm using
my keyboard what they found in their
research and this allows you to navigate
individual series and
i'll show you a screen reader demo in a
second but
one of the things that they found was
that for some users they preferred using
a data table when the data was
relatively simple so you're able to view
data table which doesn't work out that
well on a slide
i have to use my mouse i apologize
and you can export the data if that's
what you want again like accessibility
is not a one-size-fits-all type of
situation
sonification i did not create this one
but um here is a cool demo of it
[Music]
that allows somebody who otherwise
wouldn't be able to
um kind of take in that information for
themselves to to hear patterns without
um
without it being described to them um
which was a feature that people wanted
and i know we had
a low vision user accessibility expert
who showed his experience in what it was
like to get pattern from personification
and that was incredibly meaningful to
him you know like
for me i'm like i can't remember how
this goes but
if you're um
for some people that is a great way to
get the information
um i also wanted to show you
an example of voice oh sorry voice input
i had to embed this so that i can have
my closed captions on for you
um so
this video demonstrates using dragon
version 15
to navigate interactive features of high
charts by announcing the accessible
names
of buttons and controls
click jaws
click jaws
click voiceover
click voiceover all right so i'm going
to end it there but that is using voice
input to click and drill down on data
series which
um is pretty neat
screen reader accessibility now this is
one part of it um
this is for screen reader accessibility
for individual points so one of the
things that they found again with user
studies was that
rather than having these really long
descriptions a lot of users preferred
that
um
that they get the information only when
they need it so i and i apologize about
this more video situation um so this
allows a user who
can use their keyboard to hear what is
happening at each point
one december 2010 34.8 percent nvda 1
december 2010 20.2 percent voiceover it
to may 2012 30.7
voiceover 3 january 2014.
cool
um and oh by the way
you might note here and this will come
up more later is that this is actually
um these are the most common desktop
screen readers
and
um
they
as you'll find out as i continue
they do not all they all have platform
specific and sometimes browser specific
accessibility apis so when you're
testing something it's not as easy as
being like use a screen reader they
actually all work a little bit
differently so testing is pretty
expensive
is it perfect
i don't know
um
i it's it i can't say but it's pretty
darn good is it impressive
yes
um is it way better than anything i'd be
able to do by myself
absolutely
so
why is it so impressive
this gets out what i was talking about
before
um
so assistive technology and the
accessibility tree so this is an example
with an application um so an application
is broken down into something called an
accessibility tree and those nodes can
be grouping nodes um that
are hierarchical or they can be
individual elements that you can
interact with in different ways
so it could be something that you could
click that could have a state that could
have a role
um and again this is a platform specific
accessibility api that creates that
accessibility tree
and then that goes from the assistive
technology to the user
so
um i guess i'll go over this quickly
just because i've taken a longer time
than i thought so an example this would
be with using voiceover you know that
the app translates an element into an
accessibility node
voiceover visits it voiceover
announces what it is
then the user this in this case would be
using um the keyboard they can press it
voiceover tells them what they did
the click event is routed back to the ui
element and
something happens
um
cool you might be thinking like well i'm
not developing
that
turns out it's pretty similar
on the web so in the browser and
browsers vary from
in terms of what they do uh this pretty
much goes to the um the dom the document
object model the tree that is created
for us um
and what screen readers see is
controlled by their
accessible written internet application
roles that's arya and the html so it's
in parallel the tree is painted into a
visual ui
and transformed into an accessibility
tree
which varies by browser which is then
read via the native
api for the assistive technology and
brought to the user
so
this is like not a simple thing to solve
um
and
yeah cool all right so
now i'll talk a little bit about what i
learned from using the accessibility
module this is a chart that i
created um
you know are using high charter i'm not
showing you the code because it's super
long but don't worry it's in the source
documents
um it's navigable by keyboard i can
export um i have an annotation and
um
yeah all right so
what's the magic here here's where some
of the screen reader cool stuff comes in
and maya i think mentioned this before
so with twitter so if you go and you
inspect the html for this um
it's actually created a hidden screen
reader region that if you look at its
aria hidden equals false so that means
that
it's visible to a screen reader um
and then there are other regions of the
chart that are hidden but it is visually
hidden to a user who's looking at a
visual representation
um and then this back from that first
article this is where ted um
and the developers added the structure
description of a chart that could
benefit screen reader users
um such as the chart type access
information which
is partially automatically generated and
a long description of what's found in
the chart provided by the creator
so again it's not one size fits all
right um part of what they found was
that users
they wanted
not to have to go through every element
in order to get the description or they
wanted to be able to skip certain
elements early on
and this is a case where you have
two different ways of accessing similar
information that accommodates different
users
so the default format for that screen
reader section is um so the chart title
basically
the type description what kind of chart
it is chart subtitle chart long
description
i
will get back to that in a moment
um a play is sound button if you have
sonification
disabled the view table button can you
see me highlighting oh oh god what just
happened i'm sorry i could see it yep
cool i'm glad you could see it and now
i'm back so far
um
and i'm sorry if anybody's motion
sensitive close your eyes i'll tell you
when it's
back
all right so
that view table button um
comes up pretty quickly and that's
because for
simple
for simple uh data structures a lot of
people preferred that
and the chart long description some
people don't like that and there's an
easy way for them to skip it
so again making different affordances
for different
um personas
so for that penguins chart i showed you
before what does my screen suitable
section look like um again title and
chart info
flipper length versus bill that's you
know the title that i entered um
it tells you what kind of chart it is a
scatter chart how many data series three
and then um a subtitle that i added
myself
um axis descriptions and ranges
these um
this is a combination of auto generation
and user generation so for example when
i wrote this code
i
the x-axis description i specifically
wrote out displaying flipper length in
millimeters
um
knowing that it would be in this special
area um
and that they would be able to then skip
the x-axis description elsewhere
the range can either be
automatically generated which is what i
did in this case or the developer the
i'm creator can write it in there
sometimes it can't be automatically
generated because let's say it's
categorical you're going to be like
range from broccoli to
carrot
it's not a good example but that's what
i'm thinking of
right um and then the annotations and
this is a big um
this is a a big deal that i didn't
really know about and i'm showing you an
example that just has one annotation but
there's another one in the blog post
that has lots of them
is that the chart annotation summaries
come up because often with annotations
we're saying what the most important
information is
so it says um some stuff is what you
write into
sorry
horizontal scrolling is great so
um you write in your annotation but it
also is using information from the data
points so flipper that's the x-axis of
this length and the y-axis of this
length that can be automatically
generated so a combination of human and
technology working together
all right so i
skipped over the chart long description
uh before
where you are most irreplaceable you're
not irreplaceable at any point but um
this is
where you can say more and what belongs
there well
it depends
and it depends on what well a couple of
things one is both the intention of the
chart
so
what what you're trying to convey and it
depends on whom you ask
so in the user studies
um
as i mentioned before they found that it
was important that it be skippable
but um in some other research which
wasn't done by high charts that came out
oh what belongs there in general
a text summary of the visualization
making sure to describe trends or
patterns in the visualization
but
different kinds of description
contain different kinds of content
and um this was a study done recently
about a four-level model of semantic
content in different descriptions
um
these four levels the first one is kind
of the stuff that i covered
automatically um so the elemental and
the encoded properties that's things
like title legend chart type what are
the ranges
um
second level was um statistical concepts
in relation so things like computable
descriptive statistics and now as there
are statisticians here
you might start to think like wow i
definitely don't want
a computer automatically saying
the descriptive statistics that are the
wrong statistics for the kind of um
for the distribution i'm showing you
know you you can see how human
intervention would be useful there
um the third level was perceptual and
cognitive phenomena which basically
means stuff conveying kind of the
overall gist of complex trends and
patterns exceptions outliers
and then the fourth level was contextual
and domain specific insights so
um like social and political
explanations for trends and um stuff
that depends on an individual's reader's
subjective knowledge
and some of the interesting takeaways
from this study were that um
description so the study was done with
both blind and cited reader groups and
they found that descriptions are
important to both blind and cited reader
groups
but that those reader groups differ
almost diverged significantly on which
semantic content they ranked as most
useful so not everybody
says that the same stuff is useful and
this was interesting to me because
they're really saying like okay um what
you think as a sighted person might be
most useful
is
might be very different from what a
blind user thinks
and then um even within that access to
meaningful information is strongly
reader specific
all right so that was kind of i and i
really really recommend you check out
this paper it's very very good
running out of time so lessons learned
um
through using this api use tools they're
great but i learned a ton from using
this tool
um and stuff that i wouldn't have
thought of and different tools make
different things easy or harder um and
you learn a lot
but don't rely on tools so there are
limitations to technical fixes
um
accessibility isn't one size fits all uh
in fact what helps one user could be a
hindrance to another so things like
patterns for dual encoding can be really
useful to some people and can be really
distracting or even harmful to others um
and
you need to make affordances for those
user preferences um look to experts
there are people who are experts in this
um
but it is uh it is kind of a nascent
field there aren't really great um
wcag guidelines on
um
on semantics for things like svg um get
feedback get feedback from lots of
different maya covered this nicely
um and keep learning i i think that's
one of the things i've learned like
literally since i did this the high
charts api has changed and improved um
and
this it really is kind of a young
a young area of study so
um these you can access my slides these
are has the r code and the working
examples um the blog post series which
if you're interested in you can see them
um
resources um the 10 guidelines for
database accessibility oyster mosaic
who's one of the high charts core
developers
um that paper i mentioned earlier um the
accessible visualization via natural
language descriptions the dataviz
accessibility and advocacy group has
like an ever-growing
um
collection of resources
this really great piece i read by a
low vision user who uses screen reader
every day on alt text it's really short
and one of the best things i've ever
read about it it was all these things i
as a user would never think of
and then the ally project is a great
like meta resource for more resources
and then references there were a lot of
them and don't worry you'll be able to
scroll and see these and also i can
render it so they're larger and that is
it
thank you so much mara thank you for all
those resources at the end too
i know i shared the slides earlier but
it might be helpful to reshare them in
the the chat right now too
um they're no longer coming up i just
pasted it again sorry okay
thank you
um i see a few questions on
slido that have come through and
and then the zoom chat
but i do want to just bring everybody in
to the conversation too so i know this
is kind of hard on zoom but
if you want to
jump in and ask questions too you can
raise your hand on zoom
um
or it can
call on you from the zoom chat we'd love
to just learn from you all as well what
resources have been most helpful for you
or
or other packages and things you want to
share with people too
mara i see david had asked a question on
zoom
does anyone know a way to add
sonification that isn't with high charts
and i think there were a few
recommendations of packages too
i know there are ways
and they don't all use high charts i i
think one of the um
let me get back to you on that i haven't
used the other ways but there are other
ways and um that sonification studio
isn't actually part of high charts you
can use it for anything
i know there's another native way too
yeah i think re revise shared sonify and
tune our packages
that you can use
but yeah any other recommendations of
packages too would be really helpful
uh let's see i see zach you have your
hand raised do you want to
jump in live
yeah candy
so
uh this one's for maya so the
about the clicking on the shiny app
is that
would i have i've kept her gg plot at
the moment would i have to learn plotly
or is there a gg plot way of doing it
uh
um to
have two is the really funny thing yes
you have to um
no you can totally use ggplot outputs
again it gets into like
creating all text for those outputs
and i don't know if anyone has played
around with or done research on like
when you
dynamically create a plot in shiny
also have alt text come along for the
ride with it um i personally like my
journey geeking out into accessibility
is very young um very green in the space
but i'm super excited about trying to
automate
some level of description mara talked
about the dangers in doing that but also
like the baseline of having nothing like
it's better than that so there's that
gray area
um theoretically
if you render it as an svg
then you could create events on those
svgs if you made it
so that you could focus on each one of
those
then you would have aria roles that you
would have to manually assign to them
saying how they were related back to the
chart so where they come from and then
the data
that is there's no standard for this but
the data that is with it that's where
i'm like huh boy would it be easier if i
had a tool that already did this for me
like that's where i'm like i don't know
how to do that but
um i
it's possible
yeah because that that's the big thing
that i took away
was
yeah a lot of my i know that i commented
on earlier i use a red amber green
because of course everyone goes use the
rag system which of course red and green
aren't the most accessible for color
blindness that was that was a thing that
i picked up on so yeah thank you very
much for you
but you can you can use text with that
too like for example in the shiny widget
i had that those if you picked like blue
text on a blue background the box turned
red but under it i had that with a with
an x on it you know so if you because
that's like traffic lighty
norm you want to leverage things that
people can see in the real world but
also you want you can
like how mara talked about dueling
coding thinking about um just giving
users and like ah opting into different
ways of uh interacting with the data
yeah thank you
thanks zach
um i see al or al sorry i'm not sure if
that was just um your initials on zoom
asked
for a user who is blind or partially
sighted and has never seen a scatter
plot
is it helpful to tell them that it's a
scatter plot
what will they do for with that
information
also how do these charts handle screen
zoom
or magnifying glass yes so high charts
deals with zoom and magnifying that's
like another one of their big features
and mobile
um again i'm like great i don't have to
build anything like that
um and
yeah so that is actually in that paper
on semantic content one of the
recommendations they're like here's
where you could go into detail about
what it means to be a scatter plot you
know and um
so that's one option
and that's also where you kind of want
to gauge your
your audience um
is saying the chart type relevant well
if uh
if you've never seen it before if you
have seen it before
i i don't think that um
it might say something about how you'll
end up navigating it if you become
familiar with it so for example for a
scatter plot you're going to want to be
going between groups and zooming in
um
but yeah it's i
like i've said many times before what's
useful for one user isn't necessarily
useful for another one so
i'm just adding to that too if you like
let's say we have radio buttons where
the user can toggle between seeing a
scatter plot or a line plot then you
need some indication indicator an aria
role that that okay i'm seeing the thing
that i clicked in the other thing you
know so it just ties it could tie it
back in that way too
great thank you
i see caleb had asked on zoom earlier is
the annotate function built into ggplot
i think that was during your talk maya
yeah there's there's a million packages
that people that are smarter than me
have written as well like uh
there's
it's escaping me i'm sure someone could
throw it in the chat like a labeler that
will label all your points and you can
even set like if else statements to only
label things you care about
thank you uh and there's and gg labeler
there you go
i was going to write that in the chat
because i'm going to share the link to
that so we just remember to share it
later
um i'm also going to stop the recording
right now too if people want to just
like jump in the conversation and that
would make people feel more comfortable
too but
let me stop that but thanks all
[Music]
you